bonsoir bienvenue donc à ce que votre
émission culturelle tout de suite le
sommaire de l'émission l'association
l'est pas c'est le passé à me parler du
passé d'elancourt propose une visite
guidée du village jusqu'à la colline ce
dimanche et pour en parler en plateau
jean flattot le président de
l'association jean françois audric
expose en ce moment à la commanderie des
templiers d'elancourt
il ne peint que des paysages des
paysages inventé au regard de prévost
médiatrice culturelle nous a servi de
guide et puis charles gonzalez craie
antonin artaud le 30 mai à la maison de
la poésie de guyancourt il ya nicolas
gervais a rencontré le poète mais tout
cela pour te passer à une page
exposition
je voulais des denrées titre jean
françois gaudry expose ses paysages
jusqu'au 5 5 juillet à la commanderie
des templiers d'elancourt l'artiste
peintre ne se consacrent qu'aux paysages
une oeuvre surprenante que nous détaille
rien ne prévoient les médiatrices
culturelles des images signées williams
est la montage de xavier jaglin
jean-françois oudry ne travaille pas sur
ce qu'il voit dans le réel ou à travers
des photographies il invente ses
paysages pour mieux comprendre son
travail oriane prévost médiatrice
culturelle nous a servi de guide qu'ils
représentent des paysages qui sont
inventés mais dans chacun de ses
paysages et bien on peut trouver la
trace de l'activité humaine alors on va
jamais trouvé d'êtres humains l'être
humain n'est pas représentée mais à
chaque fois vous avez vraiment la trace
les stigmates de l'activité humaine vous
allez avoir des trous des routes des
creusets les avoirs des talus on voit
qu'il ya eu quelque chose peut-être un
paysage post industrielle ou alors
paysages agricoles ou d'android et
carrière peut-être enfin en fait on voit
vraiment ces traces de l'activité
humaine
une volonté de sa part de travailler sur
le noir et blanc ont véritablement il a
voulu faire cet exercice mettre en avant
le noir et blanc s'exercer à ce travail
peut-être si on peut faire une
comparaison avec la photographie
on s'aperçoit en regardant bien les
oeuvres que finalement il est de la
couleur il ya des taches de couleurs qui
ressortent et en s'approchant on voit
véritablement qu'il n'y a pas du tout
que du noir et blanc il ya du bleu du
violet du orange du verre mais
effectivement c'est se couper de
forcément des couleurs très vives et
c'est un petit peu dit soudan dans le
tableau
on se rend compte en fonction du point
donc on regarde le tableau d'où on
regarde le tableau que certaines choses
peuvent sembler très structuré très
précis des comptes on s'en approche et
bien finalement tout est fou mais qu'une
tâche qui de loin que faire penser à un
arbre dès qu'on s'approche un petit peu
le même sans être à 10 cm en étant à 50
voire 1 mètre et bien finalement ça
devient qu'une tache parmi d'autres
une notion de figuratif et abstrait dans
le travail plastique ou jean-françois
audry veut montrer le paysage tel qu'il
imagine avec une note toujours de poésie
à découvrir jusqu'au 5 juillet
et puis toujours en matière d'exposition
une autre explosion cette fois la ferme
du mousseau toujours un elancourt 8,8
toile d'un des classiques de la série la
danse idéal des constellations en
référence au tf texte divagations de
stéphane mallarmé ce sont des toiles
grand format qui sont ici présentés
c'est jusqu'au 31 mai l'entrée libre et
puis une autre exposition cette fois de
gravures signées caroline salette et
irène clara à la maison de la poésie
depuis ion course et jusqu'au 19 juin la
du mercredi au vendredi de 14 heures à
18 heures l'entrée est libre
elle va ouvrir une page patrimoine les
amis du passé des locaux organisent une
visite du village et de la colline
d'elancourt cela aura lieu ce dimanche
et pour en parler en plateau avec nogent
plateau bonsoir vous êtes le président
de l'association alors une balade qui va
démarrer à partir de 9h 9h30 au rendez
vous au bassin de l'aneth et où est ce
que vous allez emmener les visiteurs
baladeur le rendez vous et on va dire à
l'intérieur de la fondation mais quiniou
là où il y à un parking
dans le périmètre de la fondation
militants d aurillac la fondation
méquignon c'est déjà quelque chose à
voir voilà ce alors la fondation
méquignon et donc rôle de rendez vous
est donné à 9 heures et y aurait une
inscription sur place 5 euros pour le
café et les croissants le matin et puis
les boissons d'un billy
est
ce qu'on va pouvoir voir ce que ça que
ça se termine vers le retour est prévu
vers 13h donc ça veut dire une matinée
entière de promenade dans dans est en
cours pour découvrir quoi alors pour
découvrir en fait le but c'est de
démontrer notre colline la colline
d'elancourt plus haut sommet
d'ile-de-france en partie artificielle
mais toujours est il que c'est partir
comme chaque année nous balade de la
fondation matignon parce que le
directeur mathieu pujol va nous ouvrir
la chapelle qui sera ouverte quand nous
reviendrons et puis on pourra commenter
sur
l'édification de cette fondation qui
existe depuis plus
expliquer à quoi sert cette on peut
alors à cette fondation l'a longtemps
était
c'était des orphelins des orphelins qui
étaient là ont encadré par les bonnes
soeurs très longtemps et puis maintenant
céder va dire des enfants du coup de
grandes difficultés dans des familles
qui en d2d soucier qui sont placés et
qui sont scolarisés soit il encore dans
les environs et c'est le conseil général
ma connaissance ce qui financent et si
tu trouves ça q des fondations 667
formation il ya une chapelle qui n'est
jamais ouverte qui sera rien et alors
c'est que j'appelle elle n'est plus
ouverte mais depuis quelques quelques
temps elle a été réhabilitée rénové il y
avait un gros travail à faire et à
l'occasion donc de notre balade annuelle
puisqu'on parle toujours ou quand on
arrive quand on revient de l'avoir fait
périple toujours est il que là on nous
avons accès et il ya des choses à voir
alors on pourrait continuer mais je sais
qu'elle sera à découvrir en dépôt
dimanche à partir de 9 heures la
fondation méquignon la chapelle de la
fondation et ensuite pour aller jusqu'à
la colline d'elancourt la fameuse
colline d'elancourt vous allez passer
participe donc je vais citer mes deux
amis qui ont surtout travaillé pour le
circuit et et les commentaires à savoir
pierre thomas et jean luck à plein et
nous avons donc un déport de la
fondation nous passons entre deux étangs
de la muette qui ont été dans des années
qu'à la fin des années 80
réhabiliter rénové et ensuite la route
principale qui va à trappes il y aura
commentaire quand y'a eu justement
l'édification parce que de c c et ans et
en cas de puissant tonale et qui a eu un
gros problème en moins doués ça
peut-être servi à stocker en partie
audio est ensuite dans ce qui permet
d'éviter des inondations et alors il ya
un trou qui est derrière
enfin derrière le privé n'est nullement
les transformateurs électriques qui
servait on croyait pour faire de la
voile non c'est en cas de pluie
centennale pour stocker pour pas clos
vienne dans le village donc j'avais été
bien prévu et on attend toujours un lac
ou des centenaires
il ya eu depuis un mois d'où l'année
dernière qui était terrible un 1/4
d'heure alors toujours est il rod
principal des trappes commentaires pour
le canton va passer devant l'église
ensuite carrefour de les revendre rire
ou des gâtines donc on va expliquer
le comment elle a été édifiée
cela voire de les revendre et ou de
larmes andré avec l'arsenal mais je ne
dis pas ce qu'est ce qu'est le petit
arsenal
ce sera une question ne fait pas de jeux
comme ça ensuite on prend le chemin de
la julienne perpendiculaire à la route
des gâtines et ensuite on arrive tout de
suite où il y a les jardins familiaux
qui sont à la base alors pour certains
celle en cours pour d'autres c'est
trappe mais on va pas dire non plus
puisque c'est la limite sur le plateau
et ensuite nous contournons le on va
dire la colline de la revanche 'par le
bas' parce que là on veut prendre des
pentes faible and puisqu'il ya quand
même un dénivelé de 130 net et mais pas
d'habitude c'est 8 10 km de ses 5 km
alors donc on contourne côté sud on
ne rend pas tout de suite et ensuite où
on va atteindre la route goudronnée de
bord d'une petite route goudronnée qui
va jusqu'au sommet qui est quand même
une pente
alors là
habillez-vous quand même mis parce que
ses ventes e et puis il va pas pleuvoir
je suppose touchait du bois est toujours
que lala donc les commentaires vont être
justement sur comment 7 7 collines a été
aménagé et pourquoi et or ont peint avec
des travaux d'excavation et ensuite les
carrières mort entre rappelé l'histoire
de carrier et surtout ou voile qui on
voit à 30 kilomètres à la ronde on voit
la tour eiffel et là on va parler au
sida ville nouvelle et du quartier des
encours la clé de saint pierre parce que
là on était sûr plaisir est maintenant
c'est les locaux et et alors et on
revient l'histoire là où il y aurait une
porte en porte un peu plus réellement
fin on va céder et on revient au bassin
de la muette où carla par le ch brille
par le chemin des gâtines au dessus si
vous voulez pas loin de là marc au sol
et il y à une borne ne va pas dire ce
qu'il ya dessus et on défend
justement la bohème et donc c'est
dimanche à partir de 9 heures rendez
vous au bassin de la meuse pour ceux qui
veulent participer à cette balade qui
vous ont traîné donc vous avez vu tout
un périple pourra aller jusqu'à la
colline à d'elancourt redescendre et
repartir au bassin de l'annuaire des
comores notamment la chapelle de la
fondation mes clients mais aussi
d'autres choses à découvrir tiendrait
avant qu'on termine cet entretien qu on
parle rapidement aussi de l'autre aspect
de l'association du pain aux amis du
passé les en course et les vignes chez
parce qu'on sait que vous occupez
effectivement notamment la ferme du
mousseau il ya une exploitation
d'environ 160 pieds de vigne welte
achats chez tbwa figure alors des
bénévoles dites-nous rapidement le
profit si vous permettez
manche ce que l'on apporte le midi
étaient au partage alors elles ont gardé
alors effectivement parce qu'ils
nombreuses années puisque la vigne a
plus il existe depuis plus de 20 ans et
nous recherchons quelques personnes
bénévoles qui voudraient donner un coup
de main c'est juste quelques heures
c'est le jeudi matin ont des vignerons
et vigneronnes 1 pour l'aménagement
s'occuper de la ville mais également de
la cave de vin mais on passe au risque
du jus de raisin et bien un lien avec
les écoles et on fait on remet un
fascicule pédagogique aux enfants un
petit pour les enfants est un grand un
grand feu comment dirais-je grande
brochure avec la vie de la vigne pendant
un an ou aux enseignants qui accompagne
les gens si vous voulez accompagner
l'association des amis du passé de
l'encours cheruiyot ignorons bénévoles
n'hésitez pas à contacter l'association
qui recherchent donc des personnes je
crois que ces heures environ 2 à 3 fois
par mois la cession de contacter moi
tout à fait votre numéro affiché
j'ai pas eu encore pourtant on avait eu
ces idées figées pas malléable
à merci en tout cas j'en fais tous
d'être venus sur plateau de kiosque nous
parler à la fois de votre recherche de
bénévoles mais surtout est évidemment de
cette balade qui aura lieu dimanche à
partir de 9 heures au bassin de la meuse
à elancourt pour découvrir le passé de
la ville d'elancourt et les trésors
cachés que vous nous réservez merci
beaucoup à vous est venue sur le plateau
de casse merci et puis une autre visite
toujours retour un retour sur le passé
cette fois c'est à trappes ce sera
samedi à partir de 14h de l'ancien
château au carrefour des routes
commerciales aux grands ensembles de la
reconstruction qui change le visage de
la ville redécouvrez donc l'histoire de
trappes une visite commentée par le
musée de la ville
et on passe maintenant la chronique
signifie comme tous les mercredis voavy
de spectateurs ce mercredi au micro de
matt hill de capvern
j'ai bien aimé c'est sympa en plus du
coup on peut on peut voir les acteurs
qu'on habitude effectivement de voir
dans le petit journal tout ça dans des
rôles un petit peu plus dramatique - il
ya le côté comique mais on les voit
aussi plus humain entre guillemets et
c'est sympa
je pense que c'était une bonne comédie
sans prétention mais réjouissante bien
interprété
je dirais nouveau
et bomba plus que diakité des acteurs
que je me ce soir là couple a une fille
qui vivent ensemble et séparément c'est
un film qui était vraiment excellent les
acteurs étaient formidables j'ai
beaucoup aimé c'est prodigieusement
interprété tout d'abord les dialogues
sont riches la trique et fils d'amener
et la reconstitution historique et d'une
grande facture donc si vous pouvez
apprécier passer un grand moment
voilà maintenant le coup de coeur d'un
professionnel du septième art ce soit
gaël pinault a du grenier à sel de
trappes
bonjour cette semaine je voudrais vous
parler de notre nouveau coup de coeur ça
s'appelle les châteaux de sable c'est un
film réalisé par olivier dahan une
comédie dramatique olivier dahan nous le
soutenons puisque nous avons travaillé
avec lui nous au grenier à sel dans le
cadre de la promotion de nos dispositifs
d'éducation au cinéma et donc les gens
il avait déjà fait un film est là il
revient ça faisait longtemps qu'il
n'avait pas fait un long métrage il
revient maintenant avec ce film qui
s'appelle déjà d'autres salles donc dans
le rôle titre nous retrouvons emma de
caunes elle jouait les eaux nord qui est
une
jeune photographe qui a eu du succès
pendant un moment et maintenant plutôt
dans le creux de la vague elle vient au
plus de perdre son papa qui était jouée
pâquis joué par alain chamfort on le
voit de temps en temps à apparaître dans
le film et elle doit vendre la maison de
son père qui se trouve en bretagne donc
on va passer un week-end dans la maison
en bretagne elle se fait accompagner aux
voitures par son ancien petit ami
qui s'est remis en couple et de
quelqu'un d'autre donc la situation où
vous en doutez est un petit peu
compliqué
on est très content de retrouver
emma de caunes et aussi les autres
acteurs qui sont avec elle puisque sont
vraiment très bons c'est un film très
agréable pour ça on a une
une très belle bretagne très bien filmé
et donc tous à vous retrouver les
horaires sur aussi la grogne à celle
trois cantons
ces deux là n'auraient jamais dû se
séparer voilà ce qu'on pourrait se dire
en les voyant voilà les bêtises que l'on
pense
gonzalez propose un spectacle autour de
l'univers si particulier à la limite de
la folie d'antonin artaud c'est à
découvrir le 30 mai à la maison de la
poésie de guyancourt et nicolas gervais
a rencontré charles gonzalez
comédiens exceptionnels il a été très
présent cette année à la maison de la
poésie de saint quentin en yvelines où
il présentera le 30 mai sa toute
nouvelle création adapté de son livre
récit d'une noce obscures voici sous vos
applaudissements
l'extraordinaire charles gonzalez dans
le kiosque c'est maintenant c'est tout
de suite on y va la partie allait la
maintenance et la
messieurs
lillois
la coutume
vous concerne le droit de mesurer esprit
géré toutes deux à peu près dix mois les
habitants de la région enfin des dessins
entoure nous avons monté un atelier
autour d'artaud voilà autour d'artaud et
autour de l'enfermement d'artaud
d'artaud est très peu connue finalement
le connaître comme étant un aliéné mais
c'est un très grand poète combien êtes
vous par exemple pour qui le rêve du
dément précoce les images dont il est la
proie sans autre chose qu'une salade de
mots le 30 mai oui à 19 heures j'écris
bien un bouquin à partir d'une photo
d'artaud en voir tôt sur un assis sur un
banc public dans un jardin comme on line
il pourrait être ici va à côté de son
médecin en blouse blanche et ça m'a paru
comme si artaud et le médecin étaient
des jeunes mariés vraiment et c'est la
veille du départ d'artaud de l'hôpital
psychiatrique
voilà et j'en ai fait un poème mais je
ne suis pas écrivain je suis un acteur
qui écrit demain je me fait la malle -
et antonin le jardin barran cas del
cobre si l âme à adré il y ait une mare
près du banc dans le jardin c'est ici
que je les saisies aux frondes ainsi
fournier m'a proposé donc d'opérer
spectacle et voilà on va le créer le 30
mai ici il y aura également au tour de
ceux de ce spectacle une carte blanche
nicolas appartement je vous inviterai
aussi des amis camarades acteurs on ne
peut pas être acteur sans avoir se sont
heurtés avec art au world in moi je suis
fâché
vous êtes encore vous avez dû en faire
verdière et un wii fréquence est
surréaliste il écrit comme ça en
rentrant le soir mais c'est pas bon
alors il projette sur arte ou un génie
il fréquente les surréalistes il ne et
puis surtout c'est qu'ils mentent
charteau un grand génie donc il s'impose
comme étant son protecteur médecins et
on est à la limite même d'un état
amoureux à l'époque la médecine n'était
pas celle d'aujourd'hui et les
électrochocs verdière ne voulait pas
détruire arthaud 1 il pensait réellement
le remettre sur pied mais il l'a
détruite au calme en quoi la poésie
merde n'est pas un jeu de l'oie avec
lesquelles on la crée les mots voler les
mots soufflés pas de mots écrits vous
êtes vous oui vous le sel malade
mentalement malade mental qui tire du
mal un délire de persécution
car vous ne cessez de me persécuter
alors que je croise au ciel
vous êtes mon persécuteurs j'en suis
témoin le seul témoin de moi même mais
je vous aime bien le docteur verdière
lui administre plusieurs électrochoc
dont l'un lui pulvérise une verte r1 et
donc il est totalement tétanisée à
l'époque il n'y avait pas ce ne sont pas
des camisoles 2 cynique ce ne sont pas
des médicaments mais sont des électrodes
que l'on met 6 sur les tempes et on
envoie une décharge électrique très
puissante et le patient fait un sommet
très violent voilà et art tout tombe à
terre et cassé mon werther et ça lui
évidemment ça c'est ça ça me perturbe
énormément psychiquement il entre la en
en poésie noire il évoque le pays hôte
son voyage chez les indiens chez terre
ou à reims mais de là certains disques
qu'il rentre en folie mais non ils
rentrent dans une espèce de de voyance
poétique nicolas voyait pensez-donc
verdière le mal vient imposer sa chimie
à l'organisme humain sashimis
c'est tout et seulement cela comme
aurait pu l'écrire rimbaud par un long
immense et résonnait dérèglement de tous
les sens un dérèglement de tous les sens
mais par contre heart ok ce médicament
ne peut pas être raisonnée alors ça
donne une poésie qui parfois est très
hermétique mais qu'il faut c'est très
étrange vous voudrez pendant le
spectacle 30 mai qu'il faut subir il
faut en prendre on ne comprend pas tout
si vous voulez mais on prend des
fulgurances et ça c'est très très très
très beau comment faites-vous pour
travailler un market autre visage
son modèle gifi moi c'est moi je suis
sur scène ça donne une grande maîtrise
de soi parce que sinon on commence à
jouer la folie sur scène nicolas c'est
une catastrophe j'ai trop la même
manière la même chose avec camille
claudel comprenez s'il n'y a pas une
retenue s'il n'y a pas de distance
espèce de transmutation
mais pudeur le public va se dire mais
bon on nous sommes gênés alors que là en
jouant de la folie entre le véritable
métier d'acteur la technique veulent
paradoxe de l'acteur
la technique amène aux sentiments la
maîtrise d'essayer la le 30 mai deux de
montrer au public le mécanisme de la
folie donc il faut être très très très
très lucide c'est un jeu dangereux mais
passionnant
380 francs mais sur lesquels moi je ne
devrait toucher que 280 france et sur
lesquels encore je préfère le travail
des mouleurs et faire celui du cices
lève la voix humaine est un film qui va
sortir seul et grand v sur grand écran
cinéma un film d'une heure trente de
expérimente une nouvelle technique
certains cas belg ans le grand
réalisateur abel gance à être utilisés
c'est à dire troisièmement superposés il
se passe transactions dans le même
immeuble la voix humaine jean cocteau
cette femme au bout du fil cette femme
est habillée en homme dont vous voyez
moi qui voulais rôle de femme au théâtre
c'est toujours très très très très
ambigu tout cela mais finalement et pour
conclure cet entretien nicolas que vous
menez très bien finalement
nous sommes au à l'origine du théâtre où
les hommes jouaient les rôles de femmes
je vous rappelle que le rôle de juliette
qu'on peut être sexy rien n'était joué
par un homme
car les femmes étaient interdites ciment
de d'être qualifiée de sorcière ne
pouvait pas jouer au théâtre
voilà et après le spectacle et la carte
blanche de charles gonzales on retrouve
catherine pour des spectacles à la carte
lire la carte je vous propose la 12e
édition du versailles jazz festival qui
se termine le 12 mai 10 concerts donc
sur huit jours une master class et parmi
les invités de ce festival des talents
confirmés comme le violoncelliste 10 est
petit le saxophoniste new york à dimitri
à bastille ou encore le pianiste
manoukian il sera d'ailleurs le 12 mai à
20h30 au théâtre montansier et je
propose un extrait du concert de
l'artiste
oh
et toujours dans le cadre de ce festival
une exposition de croquis du dessinateur
cabu dramatiquement disparue lors de la
tuerie de charlie hebdo c'était en
janvier dernier cabu qui avait été
lycéen versailles une exposition donc à
découvrir la bibliothèque centrale de la
ville royale l'entrée est libre
et pour finir cette émission les deux
frères réinvente nougaro ce sera le 12
mai à 20h30 à la salle jacques-brel de
montigny le bretonneux un spectacle
entre cabaret et music-hall tarifs à
partir de 16 euros 60 nice je vous en
propose un extrait sur loire de même
france
sans témoin chance
voilà beaucoup d'humour avec les demi
frères dont qui enchante nougaro à la
salle jacques-brel de montigny ce sera
donc le 12 mai cette émission a
maintenant terminé merci de l'avoir
suivi je vous souhaite une excellente
fin de semaine